[Music]
history on book tv is next due to
videotape problems we can't bring you
james decay's book monitors we had
previously promoted instead
here's the book a better war by louis
sorley he's a military scholar who
researched thousands of hours of tape
recorded military meetings that took
place during the vietnam war
this book looks at the vietnam war from
1968 to 1975.
mr sorley spoke at the army and navy
club in washington dc
ladies and gentlemen good evening my
name is cyrus crone i'm the associate
publisher of slate magazine and i'm
honored to be here
tonight for this extraordinary event
our editor michael kinsley who
unfortunately could not be here tonight
since his regards
we're especially honored to have
secretary james schlesinger introduce
our guest speaker tonight secretary
schlesinger needs little introduction to
those of us who know him directly or
indirectly as a courageous defense
secretary
during the closing years of the vietnam
war
he was named that job when he was only
44 but already it earned a distinguished
reputation as a professor
senior member of the rand staff
director of the bureau of budget
chairman of the atomic energy commission
and director of central intelligence
please welcome me in joining dr
schlesinger
[Applause]
thank you for that uh over generous
introduction
ladies and gentlemen to a professional
historian
nothing is more exciting than getting
access to a trove of documents or
documentation
documents or documentation that
previously was unavailable and therefore
previously unanalyzed
the
tapes
of the weekly
saturday morning weekly conferences of
mcv
the military assistance command
in vietnam were made available to our
author
and he has had the pleasure of going
through those tapes which reflected in
this volume
moreover
uh there is nothing harder
than to
dispel
a pro prevailing
or dominant mythology
but this volume is likely to do so it
will have i predict a major impact
it will alter what has been the accepted
but erroneous view that the vietnam war
was inherently unwinnable i quote
arguably it was unwise
arguably it was not worth the investment
that we made but it was not unwinnable
this volume demonstrates that by the
time general abrams left vietnam
that the vietnam had been essentially
destroyed
and that the north vietnamese military
had been neutralized
in other words
by the time he left we had won
that war up to that point
that victory was squandered
for a variety of political reasons
and today
the tendency is to cling to the belief
that the war was unwinnable because of
the vested interests in making the war
on one unwinnable
it is my pleasure
to introduce the author
bob sawley
lieutenant colonel us army retired
a third generation west pointer
his grandfather went to west point and
served for 40 years his father
went to west point and sarah for 30
years his uncle went to west point and
served for 30 years
he is the complete west pointer
and he
confides in me that growing up as an
army brat there was nothing he wanted to
do more than to go to west point
thereafter he had two decades of service
to the united states army
he commanded a
armored cavalry unit
he taught at west point a special
pleasure he taught at the army war
college
subsequent to his retirement he was a
senior civilian
at the central intelligence agency
he had earned his doctorate
at the
johns hopkins university and turned that
is now turning and has been turning that
doctorate
to good use
he's in the author of thunderbolt
general creighton abrams and the army of
his times
he is the author more recently of
honorable warrior general harold k
johnson and the ethics of command
in that connection
i read the following sentence
i am pleased to report that the army
historical foundation today presented
its 1998
distinguished book award to honorable
warrior congratulations to you bob
[Applause]
this is a book that i predict will have
an impact a major impact
there is a whole list of tributes
to the author and to the book itself
i shall read only one
this is from
h norman schwarzkopf
general u.s army retired
i quote one paragraph
bob's book
is an extraordinary piece of work
that is bound to become a valuable part
of historical documentation
about the war in vietnam
it answers many of the questions that
have been too long on the minds of all
of us who fought in that war
it is also
it also is the first to set the record
straight concerning the outcome of that
conflict i just wanted to thank you for
publishing this significant piece of
history
on behalf of myself
and all of those brave americans who
served our country well in vietnam
that
is quite a tribute and i offer you the
author
of
the
volume
absolutely bob saw
[Applause]
i'm grateful to all of you for coming
and giving me a chance to say something
about this book
a better war
the unexamined victories and final
tragedy of america's last years in
vietnam
my thanks to charles crone in slate
magazine for sponsoring this reception
cyrus as you heard is now associate
publisher of slate when that magazine
began three years ago at the age of 25
he was named its editor
cyrus was born while his father was
serving in vietnam and grew up as a
traditional army brat so he's right at
home in this company here tonight
and i have another reason to be grateful
to him in that journal because they were
the first to challenge the bogus cnn
time magazine
story alleging use of nerve gas in
vietnam and the byline on that story was
cyrus's byland so thanks again for that
and i want to say how grateful i am to
jim schlesinger
one of the great public servants of our
day
and a friend who can be relied upon
thank you very much for being here
[Applause]
i'd also like to acknowledge the
presence here of two people from
harcourt brace my publisher who have
been very important to this book
my editor walt beauty
and publicist dory weintraub they came a
long way to be here today thank you both
very much
and while i don't see him here tonight
there is one other person i want to
mention he's a man named merle cribenow
who's a distinguished public servant
served five years in our embassy in
saigon and has over recent months
translated
a 1994
vietnam history of the war
that has not been published in english
and made that available to me and it was
an invaluable resource for my uh my
research i'm most grateful for moral
criminal i hope that we can get that
translation published so everyone can
have the advantage of knowing it
let me now turn to the book a better war
and in the few minutes that we're going
to take care i intend to discuss the
book by posing
and then answering four questions about
the book
first as to the title
a better war
many people would maintain there is no
such thing as a good war so
how can there be a better war
this title a better war refers to the
period that i'm discussing in this book
which is the period from 1968
through the end of the war in april 1975
and i contrast that with the way the war
was conducted in the earlier period
especially from july 1965 when we
introduced major ground forces for the
first time through the tet offensive of
1968 which is where this book book picks
up
the going in premise for the book is
that these later years are essentially
unknown
in the subtitle i say the unexamined
victories of these years
and the reason for that is first of all
that all the better known books that are
about the war as a whole
are focused primarily on the earlier
years those up to tet 1968. this is true
of stanley cornell's book vietnam
history it's true of george herring's
excellent academic treatment of the war
america's longest war it's especially
true of neil shin's bright shining light
these are all excellent books useful
books but the fact is that they are all
heavily focused on the earlier years of
the war
william colby wants to observe that due
to the prevalence of such truncated
treatments of the war
the vietnam war is known to most people
as though the historical record given to
most americans
were similar to what it would have been
if histories of world war one world war
ii stopped before stalingrad before
operation torch in north africa
before waddle canal in the pacific
in fact to show you how
predominantly the focus is on the
earlier years in in farnow's book he has
a cast of principal characters that runs
to
a very long list include such notables
as morton halperin alexander haig and
archimedes patty
but not general creighton abrams who
served in vietnam for five years and
commanded our forces there for four
so i'm arguing that it is not so much
that our understanding of the later
years is wrong
it is that it is based on a presumption
that what we know about the earlier
years carries forward into the later
years as well
that is more or less of a seamless hole
with the exception of course that we
were building up in the earlier years
and withdrawing our forces in the later
years but i have found that that
much
different things occurred in almost
every realm in the later years and that
is the focus of my book so that's the
answer to the first question why a
better war
question two is the heart of the book
how was it a better war
and i my answer is in almost every
respect in the earlier years
the uh the way in which the war was
flocked
was
an effort to kill as many of the enemy
as was possible general westmoreland in
his memoirs said that it was a war of
attrition and that he had chosen that
approach and the measure of merit
therefore was body count and the premise
was that if you could kill enough of the
enemy they would be disheartened and
they would cease their aggression
against the south and that a favorable
outcome would thus be achieved
during the years that general
westmoreland commanded we did in fact
kill an impressive number of the enemy
but that did not have the desired
outcome
in in that period of time the tactical
approach was search and destroy
in which uh large elements
went through the deep jungle very often
looking for the enemy seeking to bring
them to battle uh large set piece
battles if you will
that was a very difficult way to try to
fight a war and
even though large casualties were
inflicted
when the
forces that had gone out
the search and destroy moved on the
civilian populace was once again exposed
to the enemy who often sought to
exaggerate retribution on them
especially if they helped the allied
forces
the measure of merit in this earlier
period was body count
now we come to the period after 1068
soon after that general creighton abrams
assumes command of american forces
ambassador ellsworth bunker is our
the head of our embassy
and william colby comes out to head the
pacification program
i i consider that one of the most
remarkable triumvirates of like-minded
public servants that the the united
states has ever had the good fortune to
put into the field
they were of one mind on the war and
their outlook on the war was this is one
war of several parts and if you focus on
only one or another part
you cannot succeed in the whole the one
war included combat operations yes those
still had to be conducted
but in addition to that the things that
had been neglected in the earlier period
pacification
in the hamlets and villages of south
vietnam and especially rooting out the
enemy infrastructure there which for
years through terrorist means had kept
the population under communist
domination
and in addition to that
improving south vietnam's armed forces
so that they could gradually take over
responsibility for the security of their
own country so those were the three
things that were
that made it a better war
instead of just focus on combat
operations
in this kind of war instead of search
and destroy clear and whole was the
tactical premise
and as the main forces cleared out the
enemy from populated areas
uh especially regional and popular
forces the territorial forces which were
greatly expanded
upgraded in their weaponry and upgraded
in their training moved in to secure
those areas so the enemy could not come
back and could not exact retribution
against the people so that was an
extremely important part of it and now
the measure of merit is no longer body
count it is secured population
and that's how you tell if you're if
you're progressing in in the way that
you're supposed to be doing if you're
going to win the war
one of abram's strongest convictions and
he said this on many occasions
it is important that the command
move away
from the
overemphasized and often irrelevant body
count preoccupation toward measures of
progress more oriented to attainment of
u.s objectives
what we've been doing said abrams
tellingly contrasting the new approach
with previous tactics is sort of a
treadmill
we have to find these same units and
they're always getting ready to hit
saigon or tein in
so we go after that and we're whacking
them with b-52's tack air and artillery
and dumping in on them and piling on and
that sort of thing
and the history of that is that we go
ahead and mash it all up but then he
sends a lot more guys down and builds it
back up and we mash it all up again and
just
you know
cause a lot of casualties and so on
now the way to put a stop to it the way
to get off the treadmill
is to go after this other part which
always seems to survive
the other part was pacification in the
villages in hamlet this is the way to
run the war said abrams our war
again he said the body count does not
have much to do with the outcome of the
war
some of the things i do think important
are that we preempt or defeat the
enemy's major military operations and
eliminate or render ineffective the
major portions of his guerrillas and his
infrastructure
the political
administrative and paramilitary
structure on which his whole movement
depends
and that was another abrams insight that
it wasn't the main forces that were
supporting the infrastructure it was the
other way around the main forces needed
the infrastructure to pre-position
weaponry to provide guides to lead them
through unfamiliar southern terrain and
when the infrastructure withered the
ability of the main forces to operate in
the south was much diminished
as as 1968 neared an end abrams had now
been in command for six months formally
and
quite a bit longer than that de facto
he sent a cable to general earl wheeler
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff to
say that in pacification
we are making our major effort
so is the enemy
in my judgment added abrams what is
required now is all out with all we have
military machine runs best at full
throttle
that's about where we have it and where
i intend to keep it
the tactics of the earlier day which
involved multi-battalion and sometimes
multi-division sweeps through the deep
jungle were now replaced by much smaller
units operating primarily as
reconnaissance patrols ambushes and when
they found the enemy then
all the firepower that was available
would be brought in but he didn't go out
with divisions looking for
enemy battalions he went out with the
companies and sometimes smaller than
that
and it worked a great deal
better
a team from the department of the army
went out early in 1969 to look at how
the war was being fought if there was
any doubt in anybody's mind that it was
radically different
and by the way general fred wyant who
was serving there at the time said the
tactics changed within 15 minutes of
abram's taking command
and this team went out and and took a
look at what was happening in there and
they said u.s army units are fragmenting
with small unit operations replacing
searches by battalions and brigades and
we are now working with the vietnamese
to an unprecedented degree targeting on
the enemy among the population
rather than forces hiding in the general
jungle and pearlman said if he'd been
told this at high-level briefings this
colonel perliman who wrote this
assessment he might have been skeptical
but he said i put my faith in the
off-the-cuff comments of sea ration
consumers
and these men are unanimous in their
opinion that a new situation exists and
that our response is effective
the enemy also appeared to feel that
that was the case because after four
failed general offenses that tet 68
may of 68 september of 68 and 10 of 69
they finally and i would say finally
decided that they were going to have to
change their approach they published
cosmon which is central office for south
vietnam resolution 9 in july of 1969
and uh and from that we when we captured
a a copy very soon after that we learned
that they were changing their approach
to the war very dramatically
the resolution said in analysis directs
the vc to preserve their strength in
order to protect the war it directs that
large nva units be broken down into
smaller units and that they employ
sapper tactics and target themselves
against u.s troops and installations
that latter an effort to cause us to
expedite our withdrawal of course all
provincial local force units are to be
divided into small cells and target
themselves against the
pacification effort again a rather
delayed response that that the enemy
finally came to realize how how much of
an impact that was having
there's not time in these brief remarks
to recount all the evidence that
15 years of research have
produced and in particular those tapes
that dr schlesinger referred to over 2
000 hours of tape recorded conversation
at the saturday morning strategy
sessions and at sessions when the
secretary of defense would come to visit
saigon or the secretary of the army or
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff or the commander-in-chief pacific
from hawaii
absolutely authentic contemporaneous
material
not for show they're sitting around
trying to fight the war in the most
effective way
and
and
i am the first scholar that's been
allowed access to that material
it took me a year to listen to the tapes
i was not allowed to take a tape
recorder into the vault where they were
kept or to re-record any of the material
as a consequence i made almost 3 200
pages of single-spaced handwritten notes
on on these tapes
i had a sort of a scrunched up hand for
a couple months after that was over but
i'm glad to say it's a gotten back to
tennis condition again
but uh i i feel very privileged to have
been allowed access to this absolutely
uh wonderful historical material and
and i've used it to great uh a great
extent in the book
i'm emboldened by the results of that
research and some 500 interviews that
i've done over the course of 15 years
drawing on the material that i
gained in the course of the two earlier
biographies i'm emboldened to say there
came a point at which the war was won
the fighting wasn't over but the war was
won
and the reason i say the war was won is
that the goal of a free and independent
south vietnam
allowed to choose its own destiny
politically and economically
had been achieved
so long as the united states adhered to
the guarantees that it had given to the
vietnamese
those guarantees were
that
fast forward here just a moment to
january 1973 when the so-called paris
accords were signed theoretically ending
the war
those guarantees were that if the north
vietnamese violated the terms of the
paris accords the united states would
reinstitute combat power
in order to punish
those violations and that here we're
talking about
about error and naval power
predominantly or maybe exclusively
that
if a continued fighting erupted and
south vietnam lost major combat systems
like tanks and artillery pieces the
united states would
would replace those on a one-for-one
basis
as was provided for in the paris accords
and that the united states would
continue to provide economic support for
south vietnam
by
early january 1972
the legendary john paul van all of us
know about
in particular from neil sheehan's book
said we are now at the lowest level of
fighting the war has ever seen
today said van there is an air of
prosperity throughout the rural areas of
vietnam and it cannot be denied today
the roads are open and the bridges are
up and you might run much greater risk
traveling any road in vietnam today from
the scurrying bustling hustling hondas
and lambrettas than you do from the vc
and he said this program of
vietnamization has gone kind of
literally beyond my wildest dreams of
success
that leads me to question three
why haven't we known this part of the
story before now why has it taken a
quarter century
after the war is over
for this
reality of the later years of vietnam to
be known
one of the reasons and i'll be brief
here is as i've suggested
the better known books about the war
have concentrated on the earlier years
so that's a reason that we don't know as
much about the later years
i think to imperfect reporting i will
call it that
during the period of the war itself has
contributed to this and and here's why i
say that
most of the reporting in the later part
of the years focus still on combat
operations
and i think we can understand that most
reporters probably think as most people
probably think fighting is what wars are
all about and so we cover the fighting
work covering the war
but in reality as i hope i've
demonstrated in the view of abrams and
others in these later years
the fighting was by no means the most
important part of the war the most
important part of the war was
pacification rooting out the
infrastructure and improving south
vietnam's armed forces less visible
things harder to understand probably
harder to portray so i think an
imperfect record there is is part of
that as well
and then i think you have to say
there's been a certain amount of
distortion of the reality of what was
achieved in vietnam by those who are
opposed to american involvement in that
conflict
they have i think debuted in as in their
interests as indeed i would agree it has
been to portray everything about vietnam
in as negative terms as possible and by
and large they have dominated the
dialogue for uh even for these many
years after the war so i i think that's
a contributory factor as well and then
finally the new and authoritative
materials that i have recent just
described uh have only just now become
available and and they are um
they are an important source of new
insights in the later years of the war
and and now
i will get to question four of the
saddest and hardest question question
four is
why was the war
no longer one
and the answer is fairly short the
united states had made the
assurances to the south vietnamese that
i described
punish the north vietnamese if they
violated the paris accords provide
one-for-one replacement of major combat
systems that were lost in combat as the
awards provided and continued
economic support for south vietnam and
when it came to the crunch
we defaulted
on all three of those commitments
meanwhile north vietnam's patrons china
and the soviet union
were supporting their surrogate
with increased vigor
rather than drawing down their
their support they were building it up
in this 1994 history of the people's
army of vietnam that i referred to
earlier they they uh actually they brag
about the fact that from january until
september of 1973 in other words right
after the paris accords were were signed
they brought in four times as much
military wherewithal as in all of 1972
and and that was only the beginning
from the beginning of 1974 until the end
of the war in april 1975 say that say
the north vietnamese they brought in 1.6
times as much military wherewithal as
during the entire previous
13 years
so while we're
drying up our support for our surrogates
north vietnam is enjoying greatly
increased support from its patrons
and and i suggest that the outcome then
was inevitable and for ordained
i don't think the americans were like
hearing it said that two totalitarian
states
the soviet union and the people's
republic of china had proved more
faithful and more reliable as allies
than the american democracy
but that was indeed the fact
i want to say just a word about the
veterans of this conflict too in closing
there's a remarkable new book by a man
named bg birkett called stolen valor
which i think would be of interest to
many of you
in which he says that the true story of
the vietnam veteran has also not been
known and and he has spent a great deal
of time researching that story
we know some of some very interesting
things that are contrary to what most
people believe for example during the
period august 1964
through march 1973 the period of the
vietnam war if you will
volunteers
for service outnumbered those who were
drafted almost four to one
8 million 720 000
enlisted
2 million two hundred fifteen thousand
drafted and i don't think many people uh
know that
uh
then we we find some interesting things
from polling data taken in the decade
after the war was over the dust has
settled a little bit
the extent that dust is ever going to
settle
and we learned that
paris pollsters were told that 91
of those who
had served during this period said they
were glad they were served they had
served
percent
said they enjoyed their time in the
service
and two out of three this last is quite
remarkable two out of three two thirds
said they would serve again
even
knowing the outcome of the war
so i am hopeful that in years to come
the vietnam veterans will
finally get some recognition and some
credit that they have
so far largely been denied
now i want to tell you since i have said
the things i have said and including the
assertion that there came a time
when the war was won
i am not so optimistic as to think that
people who have held one view of the war
for let's say three decades or a quarter
century
are suddenly going to give it up just
because sorely says so
but i do hope that a younger generation
of citizens and scholars who have not
perhaps staked out such a fixed position
on the war will consider the evidence
and perhaps reach a different conclusion
and and my belief is that this is a book
of evidence a book of fact not a book of
opinion and so i think it it might have
that i hope it would have that effect
i go back at the end to the beginning to
the title a better war
the unexamined victories and final
tragedy of america's last years in
vietnam
the the words of better war come from a
quotation from robert chaplin
who for a long time covered the war in
vietnam for the new yorker
and and who said about a year after
abrams had taken command you know
it's too bad
abrams is very good
he deserves a better war
after the war was over after the boat
people after the
death of abrams and the death of
ellsworth bunker as well
someone
talked
to creighton abram's eldest son also
creighton who was in a major serving at
fort leavenworth and reminded him of
what robert chaplin had said
that his father deserved a better war
without a moment's hesitation
young creighton said
he didn't see it that way
he thought the vietnamese were worth it
so do i thank you very much
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you all very much i've kept you
standing and waiting for quite some time
i would uh take a couple of questions if
anybody has one and otherwise we can
do what every author loves to do and
that's science and books
questions sir
[Music]
authoritative authentic works on counter
insurgency
produced in the united states and in
foreign countries
which laid out all the principal's cold
turkey
and my question i guess is why did we
wait for any senior official in the
united states
national security
arrangement
to buy off on that why don't we have to
wait until finally we get to creighton
abrams who understood the problem
it's a good question but it's a really a
difficult one to answer because as you
correctly state the evidence was there
for anyone who wanted to look at it we
could have known much more much sooner
and and probably be guided to a wiser
course of action
i i know that mr mcnamara said in his
memoir that they were so busy they
really didn't have time to think about
or study the war
which which
is one of the most chilling statements
that i have ever read
but as a matter of fact mr mcnamara's
own systems analysis office was telling
him in writing and in detail
that
the approach what general westmoreland
was taking in vietnam was not succeeding
and could not succeed because it was
ignoring this infrastructure in the
hamlets and villages that i referred to
and and i
i talked to the people who made those
analyses and i confirmed with them that
they had been provided to secretary
mcnamara so
you know what happened then
only he can say and i don't think he's
offered a satisfactory explanation for
that
it is true i think that in the latter
period of the war and in the earlier
period as well the field commander was
uh afforded an exceptional degree of
latitude to decide how he was going to
fight the war within south vietnam and
uh and that was true during the year's
general westmoreland command although
year after year more and more people
lost faith in that as a viable approach
and and they were people in the
government as well as outside the
government later
the approach i've described that was
taken by abrams and bunker and kobe was
if anything little known even to their
own government because they were focused
on different issues
and i think you have to have some some
sympathy for the government in the
latter years
whatever you think about them on other
terms because they were trying to wipe
or walk a tight rope between
maintaining enough support
meaning predominantly
um
monetary support in terms of
appropriations to continue to fight the
war in some viable way
without losing the support you know of
the people and and having to
precipitously withdraw the forces
so yes there was plenty that could be
known
i think the inside of the men in the
later period was self-derived basically
not something that they learned from
think tanks and others i remember when
herman khan went out to vietnam for
example and he told general abrams that
if he just listened to him
he would make him a hero and he'd win
the war for him and abram said basically
threw him out of his office one of the
ideas that herman khan had suggested
that was that we dig a boat
around saigon
and uh that was rejected in vietnam
other questions
yes sir investigation is a difficult
mission and imagine as a difficult
mission probably evolved upon the army
if we were able to do it against all the
difficult missions
do you see any structure within the army
or the department of defense that has
the flexibility uh
today to take undertaking mission is
difficult
that's a good question but i think the
answer has to be
that uh probably the nature and the
detail of a pacification mission will be
unique to the country in which one is uh
trying to carry it out
and and my view is that we were
we were too willing to take the thing
away from the vietnamese in the earlier
years and and basically push them aside
and say we'll take care of this for you
and it was only in the later years when
kobe dis devised
a very uh
a very viable approach to pacification
and then got the vietnamese to buy it as
their own
that things started to to move in that
in that program we had had pacification
program one after another over the years
that were sounded good and then fell
with you know fell with a big thumb
both uh ambassador bunker and and mr
colby often said that president chu was
the number one classification officer in
in vietnam
he would go around the country preaching
the importance of it he put his own
prestige and shoulder behind it
and when they started bringing all the
local officials
from hamlets and
and villages to a place called vong tao
to train them in how to be better hamlet
and village officials
president xu went and talked to every
one of those classes and he said to them
you've got to go back and be a little
president in your in your own area
and then of course they could go back
and have the the uh incomparable cachet
of being able to say to their villagers
well as a president chief said to me
that went out
and and so you know i think it has to be
unique to the situation uh in the
country involved i think we can help but
we can only help
and so i think we need to be guided by
the insights of those who are indigenous
anyone else yes word
how critical was a decision i guess a
political decision in the u.s
not to expand the war beyond the south
vietnam
borders how critical was that
ultimate
result
i think you have to say that it was a
great hindrance to us of the many years
that we were not allowed to go into the
enemy sanctuaries both in north vietnam
proper and in the adjoining countries of
laos and cambodia because they built
major base camps there and and put huge
amounts of wherewithal there and then
they could withdraw there any time they
wanted to and that's one of the reasons
of course that the
strategy of attrition didn't work
because the enemy could basically
control the amount of attrition that he
that he that he gave up
when he didn't want to fight anymore he
would drew into the sanctuaries and we
couldn't follow him there so that was
made it that a non-viable strategy
you know of course that in the summer of
1970 we did make one foray into cambodia
u.s and vietnamese forces together and
it was very successful in its own terms
a lot of military wherewithal was
scarfed up and that clearly hindered the
enemy's ability to mount a major
offensive for quite a time maybe a year
until he could build those
those stockpiles back up again but at
the time we did it it was limited by how
deep it could go and by how long it was
going to last and the president
announced both of those to the enemy
right at the beginning so even when we
did it it was done
at the political level
maybe not half-heartedly but something
less than robustly i think that those
limitations however
right or wrong they may have been in
political terms were militarily quite
disadvantageous
yes i want to take one more question
please
do you have any information information
about the retribution that north vietnam
wreaked on the south after their
conquest or was that beyond the scope of
your blog no i i do treat that briefly
in the in the last chapter and in the
in the epilogue the degree
it's uh it's as sad as anybody might
have thought it was going to be
you know of course that at the at the
end of the war we uh
indelible picture of the last helicopter
leaving the roof of the american embassy
we withdrew all the americans
and 130 000 vietnamese thought to be at
risk of people
and their families
and then
hundreds of thousands of more maybe a
million in total
became so-called boat people
sought to flee their own country
tens of thousands more were put into
so-called re-education camps many never
came out alive
others were killed for their opposition
i don't think anybody knows what the
real
whole numbers are
but as a consequence of the viciousness
of the so-called liberators
after they had conquered south vietnam
there is now
what i call a new vietnamese diaspora of
maybe two million
vietnamese living abroad about a million
of them in the united states
some of them are my friends and i know
some of them are friends of many of you
that i see him here in the room tonight
and and i would like to say this too
they have been a very
positive contribution to our country to
its economy and to its culture and we we
are lucky to have them now as countrymen
but you still have to feel very sad for
them that they were essentially driven
from their own country because they
refused to live under tyranny
ladies and gentlemen thank you again for
coming this has been a great pleasure
and i'd be glad to sign your books
[Applause]
[Music]
lewis sorley is a third generation
graduate of west point he spent 20 years
in the u s army he is also taught at
west point and the army war college
later he was a senior civilian official
of the central intelligence agency
mr sorley's book a better war was
published by harcourt brace
found on the internet at harcourt.com
history on book tv is shown every
saturday here on c-span 2 at 8 and 11